قال الأمين العام لحلف الناتو إن فنلندا
ستنضم إلى التحالف العسكري في
الأيام المقبلة بعد عام تقريبًا من التقدم بطلب
للحصول على العضوية ، وقد تم تجاوز العقبة الأخيرة
عندما أصبحت تركيا
الدولة الأخيرة في الناتو لإثبات
طلب فنلندا بمجرد انضمام الدولة رسميًا إلى
حدود الناتو مع
روسيا.  أكثر من الضعف في الطول
إلى أكثر من 1500 ميل
وسيزداد حجم التحالف أكثر إذا
وافق جميع الأعضاء على طلب
السويد المجاورة ، لكن تركيا
تواصل حظر تطبيقها ، دعونا
نناقش هذا الأمر الآن مع
رئيس الوزراء الفنلندي السابق ألكساندر
الذي ينضم إلينا  الآن من فلورنسا حيث
يدير مدرسة الحوكمة العابرة للحدود
في معهد الجامعة الأوروبية ،
شكرًا جزيلاً لك على وقتك ،
لذلك يحدث انضمام فنلندا إلى
حلف الناتو ، كيف تفكر في هذه اللحظة
جيدًا ، من الواضح أنها تاريخية إنها
تاريخية من نواح كثيرة في  بمعنى أننا
ننضم أخيرًا إلى تحالف عسكري ، إنه أمر
تاريخي بمعنى أنه ربما يكون
أسرع انضمام لدولة جديدة في الناتو
على الإطلاق ، وبالطبع نعلم جميعًا
أن هذا لم يكن ليحدث لولا
وضع هذا العدوان في أوكرانيا
تاريخيًا في كثير من الدول.  جوانب تاريخية
في العديد من الجوانب ، دعونا نناقش جانبًا واحدًا
من حيث نوع التغيير الذي
يمثله هذا بالنسبة للفن كمجتمع وكدولة
للانتقال من
ما يسمى بالحياد إلى العضوية الكاملة في الناتو
في غضون عام
جيدًا.  أعتقد أنه يمكنك القول إننا كنا
محايدين خلال الحرب الباردة ، لكن ذلك كان
بدافع الضرورة وليس الإرادة الحرة عندما
انتهت الحرب الباردة ، تغيرنا إلى عقيدة
التحالف غير العسكري والآن ننضم إلى
التحالف العسكري أعني إلى
حد ما  يعني الكثير ولكن ليس كثيرًا
بمعنى أنني أعتقد أننا كنا أحد
البلدان القليلة في أوروبا التي
استمرت في الخدمة العسكرية الإلزامية
لدينا 900000 رجل في الاحتياط مائتان
وثمانين ألفًا يمكننا
حشدهم وقت الحرب أه لذا فهذا جيد  بالنسبة
لنا للحصول على الأمن من الناتو في المادة
الخامسة ، لكنني أعتقد أيضًا أننا نتمتع بقيمة
هائلة حيث أننا نضيف إلى حلف الناتو
نفسه ، ما هي المناقشات الجارية الآن
في فنلندا حول ما سيعنيه أن
تصبح الدولة عضوًا في
التحالف عبر الأطلسي الأول  يعني هل
الناس منفتحون على وجود كبير محتمل لحلف شمال الأطلسي
في بلدهم
جيدًا ، نعم ولا أعتقد أن
نقطة البداية هي أن نقول إننا غيرنا
الرأي العام بين عشية وضحاها فعليًا في
استطلاع للرأي في الفترة من 23 إلى 24
فبراير ، لذلك كنا في السابق 50
ضد عضوية الناتو و 20 مؤيدًا
والتي تم تبديلها بسرعة كبيرة
والآن وصلنا إلى معدلات الموافقة البالغة 80 لحلف
الناتو وأعتقد أن النقاش حول
نوع الملف الشخصي كعضو أه
سيبدأ الآن بعد
الانتخابات عندما  لقد حصلنا على حكومة جديدة
مثبتة ، أتوقع أن ملفنا
الشخصي سيكون شماليًا للغاية ، لذا من المحتمل أن نكون
مشابهين تمامًا لما
كانت عليه النرويج في الدنمارك وأيسلندا إلى
حد ما هذا هو الملف الشخصي الذي
ستشاهده أولاً في فنلندا ثم
لاحقًا ، السويد التي أعتقد أنها ستنضم إلى
القمة في فيلنيوس في يوليو من هذا
الصيف ،
فلنتحدث الآن عن السويد ، ما هو
شعورك حيال مغادرة فنلندا للسويد ،
أعني أنك أطلقت عرضًا مشتركًا
وكانت هلسنكي مصرة على أنك تعلم أنها
ستفعل ذلك فقط  انضم إذا
حصلت ستوكهولم على الضوء الأخضر ولكن الآن
فنلندا تسير بمفردها ،
حسنًا ، أنا مرتاح تمامًا من حيث
الصورة العامة ، وبعبارة أخرى ،
كانت السويد دولة محايدة منذ
200 عام وستكون الآن بعد شهرين
من فنلندا  أه إنضمامي إلى نيت بالطبع
كنت أفضل أن تنضم فنلندا إلى
جانب أه السويد ، لكن لم يكن هناك
الكثير الذي يمكن أن تفعله فنلندا حيال ذلك
لأن تركيا والمجر هما اللذان
قررا المصادقة بوتيرة مختلفة
لكنني واثق جدًا من أن السويد  سأكون
هناك وأعتقد أن الصورة الكبيرة
يجب أن تُؤخذ في الاعتبار وهي أن
الوضع الأمني ​​في كلا البلدين
جيد جدًا في الوقت الحالي لدينا
ضمانات أمنية فعلية أه كما هو
الحال هكذا أه أعتقد أه أنا لست
قلقًا جدًا  حول عدم انضمام السويد بالضبط
في نفس الوقت على الرغم من أنني كنت
أفضل أن
ينحدر ألكسندر ، شكرًا لك على هذه
المحادثة